oh my goodness well we got to go outside
sometime all of us do I think at some
point it is blustery out there we've got
clouds but we've also got a little bit
of clearing in some spots too uh it is a
kind of a raw morning for sure
temperatures are down in the 40s let's
check Valley temps I just updated them
all still a couple of spots hanging on
to some 50s Green Valley downtown
Aliante at 51 Nellis at 50 degrees those
winds are really blowing up in the
mountains 27 at Kyle Canyon it's been
really bumpy out there at Red Rock as
well the showers have moved off to the
East and we're looking at snow that is
come to an end in the mountains 46 at
Indian Springs 44 in Pahrump 53 in
Mesquite 43 in Searchlight right now
Boulder City in the mid 40s Laughlin at
59. check out those 20s back in Ely
Tonopah and blow freezing in Reno
speaking of the mountains we did pick up
some snow up there yesterday and let's
take a look now from Lee Canyon's webcam
it doesn't look like two feet of snow
well it didn't quite materialize winter
storm warnings were actually canceled
because the heavy snow just really
didn't come to fruition but they did get
somewhere between four and six inches
was the estimate yesterday as they kind
of Swing the webcam around live for us
let's go over some of the rain totals
and rain was really the main element of
the precipitation yesterday Harris
Springs below Mount Charleston picked up
nearly four inches of rain yesterday so
the biggest winners really for rainfall
in the lower elevations Red Rock almost
two-thirds of an inch and about a third
of an inch up in the Northwest Valley
neighborhoods anywhere from far west to
Northwest Summerlin up to Sky Canyon
Centennial Hills a quarter of an inch
around Henderson and up closer to Nellis
other than that a lot of neighborhoods
about a tenth of an inch or even less so
all of this low pressure now has just
really opened up most of the moisture
now concentrated in Northwest Arizona
snow up into Utah and we did have some
flood advice advisories posted east of
the valley yesterday last night really
those have come to an end so is the wind
advisory just a very slight chance of
some sprinkles left for us and a quick
update on tropical storm Nicole which is
now headed for the Bahamas and
eventually the east coast of Florida by
late tonight could be a minimal
Hurricane by the time it makes landfall
59 59 today it is going to be cool we'll
start to see more Sunshine but we're
going to keep the Southwest winds today
lighter winds tomorrow but look at those
morning temperatures dropping to the 30s
at night as we head into the weekend and
the days really won't warm up back to
normal even through the weekend and into
next week so keep the coats and jackets
around